35 counter-strike players have been
banned from one to five years
after an investigation into illicit
betting
all according to a report from the
esports integrity commission
and the crazy part is this might just be
the beginning
guys we're well on our way down the road
to
2 million subscribers here on our
youtube channel if you like these videos
if you dig the score's content
scroll down hit subscribe and turn on
notifications
so you never miss a video all right if
you're not a counter-strike head
you might not know who the esports
integrity commission is
or e-sick as we know them essentially
they're a third-party organization
that helps keep esports safe from bad
stuff you know
cheaters breaking the law questionable
antics
that sort of thing and they have been
extremely
active in cs go over the last year first
when they banned
multiple professional cs go coaches for
abusing a spectator bug
back in september here's esl's
punishments for all three coaches
heroics hunden is banned from competing
and coaching in esl events for a year
mibr's dead is banned for six months and
hard legion's mechanogun
is banned for a whopping 24 months or a
full
two years and then in december when they
released
a massive report claiming that there was
widespread stream sniping
happening at the highest level of
professional cs
if we had continued the investigation
and
followed through on prosecution beyond
the first two that we uncovered
we the very high likelihood is that we
would have had to ban
at least and i'm saying at an absolute
minimum
nine tier one counter-strike teams
that's 45 players out of tier one
plus coaches plus teams for
what for at least nine months
and some for longer and that brings us
to their latest investigation
a report that announces the banning of
35
australian cs go players due to illicit
betting and here's
why e6 says that they handed out these
bans quote
the offending behaviors which are
addressed within this release include
betting on matches in esic member events
betting on an individual's own matches
in esic member events
or betting against an individual's own
team in esic member events
end quote esik also noted that they'll
be bringing their report to local law
enforcement for further investigation
basically what the report is saying here
is that these 35 players were involved
in either
betting on matches that they were
participating in
or that other easic members were
participating in
which is against the rules these bans
will be in effect across e6 member
organizations which includes esl
blast and dreamhack the length of each
player's ban
was determined by the severity of their
actions and breaks down like this
betting on any e6 matches which is a 12
month band
betting on your own games which is a 24
month ban
aggravated betting which is over 10
matches is 36 months
betting against your own team is 48
months
and then aggravated betting against your
own team which is
60 months esik also noted that none of
the bans in
this report were specifically given out
for match fixing
but they did say that there was quote a
high probability
that bans for fixing would come out once
they completed their investigation
now that is a lot of bans
and while australia isn't exactly the
mecca of counter-strike and these 35
players
aren't exactly household names 35 is a
massive [ __ ] number
and this is all especially eerie because
e6 says
this investigation is not over yet in
fact they said they'd be continuing to
investigate quote
a number of other cs go leagues
including leagues located in north
america and europe
and a significant number of other
leagues in multiple game titles end
quote and for everything that australia
might
not be to the top tier of cs go europe
certainly is now there is a lot to take
in here
and players and commentators all over
the cs go world have not been shy
about sharing their opinions you see for
all the good that they do
asic is a third party organization it's
not like esports game developers like
valve or riot games
pay them to do investigations and to
hand out bins for the most part they're
underfunded and in some cases the work
is being done
completely on a volunteer basis our real
job the way i see it
is to deal with that horrible abyss that
exists between esports and betting on
esports
and i'm you know i'm not an advocate for
or against because betting
brings enormous benefits to the industry
in terms of sponsorship fan engagement
all these great things
but it also creates problems that
esports was simply
not equipped to deal with their
authority comes from the tournament
organizers they're partnered with
who honored their bands and don't let
those players play
and i think it's pretty easy to say that
having a third party organization
that operates as a watchdog for esports
is
a good thing because well nobody likes
cheaters
and it's best if professional esports
players operate without breaking the
[ __ ] law
that said this stuff is a hard job
and like their other reports there has
been some community criticisms
about this report specifically on the
most recent episode of the hltv
confirmed podcast
they talked about the issue about
betting on your own team which is
obviously wrong but when it comes to
tier
2 and tier 3 australian esports pros
betting on astralis versus navi
it's hard to say that they would have
any inside information
these are guys that literally started
playing esea premiere in australia
for like rooster 2 literally not not a
massive organization and they are
betting on the australis bay's grand
final of a tournament right then
i doubt that that guy has a lot of
inside information could you imagine
right you play football on the weekend
in
for a club and then you got banned from
playing football for your local club
down the park
with some of your you know your mates or
you know your colleagues
and you were betting on a premier league
match yeah i think it's
it's really unfair to ban some of these
players for a year you know if they're
young players
what does that do it makes it go to
valorance yeah and so we lose more
players to the other scene
now shockingly these 35 players being
banned
wasn't the only bit of news we got from
esic this weekend
about professional conduct this past
saturday esic handed out a
ten thousand dollar fine to vitality
after videos showed
that they had the official stream of
their matches against team liquid and
complexity
visible while playing in this past
weekend's blast premiere global final
event the stream was on a tv
outside the room that the players were
playing in which had glass walls the
infraction by vitality and the ensuing
fine from e6 were particularly
interesting
due to e6 investigation into stream
sniping
back in december back then they said
that pro cs go teams
watching their games on stream while
playing in them
was so common that they weren't going to
hand out bands
because it would be too damaging to the
csc they did say however that
any teams caught stream sniping in the
future would be receiving
harsh punishments so why did vitality
just get fined well here's what esic
said
quote e6's decision to find the
organization rather than disqualify
suspend
or ban the team is predicated on e6
review
of the evidence which indicates that
taking an action in the alternative
would have been disproportionate and
unfair outcome for the negligence of the
organization staffed
who whilst negligent had no intentional
malice in their actions
end quote to me this seems reasonable
because
yes they shouldn't have had to stream on
but the idea that they could gain some
kind of
unfair advantage by having the stream on
in another room completely separately
from where they're playing
it's a little farfetched before and like
the earlier of the year
uh the the stream delay was only like
something absurd like three minutes or
something
now that's a problem and i feel like
they should be looking into the people
that shoots like back then
because there had to be teams that were
doing it in the online area
in terms of now with these like five six
minute delays there's no way
there's nothing you can benefit from
you're like two three rounds in the past
it pretty much seemed like uh not
not on purpose thing and they had uh
audio and other video footage as well to
prove that
no information was passed on right
because from what what i understood that
was
what ezek researched about the vitality
situation and that's why they got
such a small client so there you have it
one weekend 35
australian counter-strike players banned
a ten thousand dollar fine for vitality
and a lot of angry fans
and oh yeah simple and navi were able to
slap
both astralis and vitality on their way
to winning the first big counter-strike
event of 2021
over at blast counter-strike there's
never a dull moment i mean i don't know
the audience loves dimitri and and the
thing is is like dimitri's actually just
exactly what you think about think he's
like in real life where
you know we're playing cs and he's just
doing everything in his power to like
make sure that you have a good time and
know what to do
and there's like people from the office
that have literally never played a
single game of counter-strike in their
whole life
and dimitri's like trying to selflessly
like
teach them how to like properly like buy
every round and like
you know what to smoke and that sort of
thing never getting frustrated always
helping out um so
yeah no it's it's fun and i mean it's
kind of honestly it's kind of led to me
playing a ton of valor because i'm just
sitting there and i'm like okay well i
like watching cs but
if i'm gonna play one of these games i'm
gonna play valor because it's easier
not not because i think it's better but
just because like
it should there's the the the
institutional knowledge that it requires
to play cs
is just it's just kind of like
mind-numbing to me i don't know i'm a
grown-ass man i don't have time for that
so